so yeah we'll talk about two studies
with the hopes that uh it increases our
chances of finding uh something uh of
interest uh to uh to both of us so yes
if anything you hear today sounds
exciting just reach out to me it would
be fun to have conversations uh so
today's talk is on environments and
problematic behaviors I want to start
the talk with uh some images um so here
is uh an image do does anyone here know
what we're looking at
yes okay always yes so I think uh those
of you that know that are nodding you
know where this is going right this is
uh the Southern State Parkway bridge to
to Jones Beach a beautiful beach in in
New York where uh if you look at this
bridge what are are you seeing about
this particular architecture you see the
people who took CS 347 with me so slowly
turn it
on well so compared to many other
Bridges you might have seen in in your
lifetime this perhaps is quite low right
quite low low in its height uh and um it
was done intentionally uh constructed
intentionally to be uh this low so that
it would restrict bus access to this uh
Beach bringing in uh poor generally uh
black and and brown communities uh to um
to the area so this is one example of
how our environments constructed
environments can uh limit uh behaviors
and uh and um change composition of of
of spaces it doesn't have to always be
this Insidious so here we're looking at
uh the uh Washington DC here we're
looking at uh the White House and and
the capital and you can see that it
they're quite far away
one mile away uh today's one mile no no
big deal we take Ubers back in the day
not so much right so here we're seeing
the construction around these areas
you're also seeing this area where it
used to be a swamp so this is another
example of intentional ways of
constructing uh our environments um here
capital and white house uh being built
far away from each other to limit the
executive sort of control over over uh
the the
legislature um so these are intentional
examples but we have other examples that
are not necessarily intentional here
we're looking at the Paris uh streets uh
where how narrow they were were allowing
uh sort of blockades to uh happen uh
During the Revolution uh and and that's
in fact the thing that was uh change
afterwards so that again is is our
environments uh shaping our our
behaviors um so I um am interest in
behaviors but I'm interest in behaviors
in the way that they are observed in in
online spaces and I'm a little bit of a
masochist I guess I I think about
problematic behaviors uh more often than
unfortunately positive ones uh so um I
think about the the role of the
environment in in in this context uh in
my work in general but also in
particular in today's talk this is what
we're going to be focused on so as I
said there are two studies that are I'm
not going to be like causely trying to
tell you an argument around like how
environment matters but sort of just
generally being inspired by that by that
intuition so the first one is going to
be focused on our social environments
that we construct for ourselves right so
we talked around like Bridges and and
roads and bridges and Roads and online
spaces are the connections that we have
to to other people uh so here uh uh uh
in my lab we're currently working on
network altering interventions to change
people's social media repertoire I will
tell you what what I mean by that in a
minute um to change those uh to change
those environments so I'm not going to
be talking about that um experimental uh
work today instead I'm going to be
talking about the work that we did uh
before that to inform uh that particular
experimental study in that we'll look at
the observational study uh uh we uh we
uh carried out to understand how these
environments social environments change
organically without us inter inter
intervening right in the second part uh
in a shorter version of uh uh the uh the
the the two I'm going to be sharing with
you a game that we developed called
guessing uh that uh is aimed at building
fun and engaging environments to deliver
a polarization uh reducing interventions
um and and we we'll talk about sort of
the design ideas of this game the
experiment that we ran with it and and
and the results that came out
so let's start with the first one where
the problematic thing that we're focused
on is information exposure information
misinformation exposure uh okay so uh
pass work on uh
misinformation um it great great studies
a lot of them are focused on individual
factors right so um things like
selective exposure uh things like
cognitive reflection in attention uh
these kinds of aspects that are leading
to uh misinformation exposure these are
really important but as I said today we
are all about the environment that's not
our Focus environmental factors uh the
most commonly paid attention to and
studied aspect is the algorithm right
the algorithm of these platforms that we
engage with is really the the
architecture of the world that we are
engaging with so that's it's a really
sort of common aspect that that people
pay attention to I would I would say
early on people would sort of assume
almost without even empirical uh stud
empirical uh sort of findings that the
algorithm is sort of the reason the
networks the the the platforms are the
reason that we're being exposed to uh
misinformation um and there's some
evidence for that but there's also I
would say some recent work that might
perhaps get us to question some of these
findings example could be the the most
recent Facebook and and Instagram um
studies so the other environment that I
think is paid less attention to uh in
the ways it's it's constructed is is the
environment that we build for ourselves
so this is sort of the demand Factor if
fuel right like that uh uh but demand
Factor can be demand for misinformation
but it might be also the way that I I
develop my own environment and how that
has implications for
misinformation uh so a good parallel of
this in media studies in communication
is uh what Kim refers to as media
repertoar so here the idea is that we
set our defaults or which news
organizations we visit on a daily basis
maybe there are homepage you know
homepages on our on our browsers and
that dictates the degree to which we get
information from where so the parallel
of this in the social network world is
the what I what I'm referring to as the
social media reportoire so by developing
the friend the connections that we
develop we basically shape the news feed
uh that we have so that's the that's the
sort of focus in today's uh talk and
I'll take you back to the uh the uh
Robert Robert Moses uh the the architect
uh that that developed uh these Bridges
uh this this this story very briefly uh
just to give you another anecdote here
so here uh there is a um um a biographer
Caro who was writing about Moses and was
talking to one of uh uh his associates
uh and and having these questions at the
time there was already legislation that
was like blocking access for for uh sort
of black people for to these uh to these
beaches and the thing that he he said
was legislation can always be changed
it's very hard to tear down a bridge
once it's built up right so that's
that's sort of the real reality of the
physical world the thing about the
online world is that it's quite easy to
break down that bridge you just unfollow
right so the question is uh given that
it's Dynamic given that things are not
just being built up but also being torn
down uh our question was can we get
people to to sort of tear down these
problematic connections and and again
the question is is it happening on its
own so we had two qu two high level sort
of sets of questions uh the first one is
around prevalence so our question was
how often are misinformation spreaders
unfollowed and for that we basically
have two snapshots of the network uh and
we're examining the degree to which
these uh these Ed just are disappearing
and because we want to have this be in
context right if I get a number how will
I know if that that number is low or
high we also uh wanted to have a control
group so we wanted to understand how uh
connections to misinformation spreaders
uh being broken down is it at the same
rate as as connections to uh non nons
spreaders so these are all around
prevalence uh but um as I said our goal
is also have to have these inter
ventions uh out in the real world so we
wanted to uh have some insights as to
how we should shape these interventions
so we um the second set of questions
related uh uh are is related to here is
the the predictors so the question is
what predicts on following a
misinformation spreader so here uh we're
sort of limited by the things that we
could get at scale from the API but it's
uh things around initial exposure
ideology Edge characteristic and
platform activity those are the aspects
that we are studying um so related to
this predictors uh we had a set of
hypothesis or uh sort of sort of deeper
I guess research inquiries in mind uh
the first set related to uh initial
exposure like the amount of initial
exposure how does that relate to the
chances that you would unfollow someone
um we could we saw it we it could go in
one of two ways so the first one uh was
what we refer to as uh reversion
hypothesis uh this is sort of uh
capturing the maybe the idea that
misinformation exposure can be
self-correcting so the more you're
exposed to misinformation at time T1 the
more likely you are going to be to
unfollow at time T2 right so that's uh
that's maybe the the sort of the
positive uh uh story if we if we see
that and this could happen for a number
of different reasons right it could be
high redundancy the more misinformation
followers uh misinformation spreaders
you
follow you know each one has sort of
marginal a smaller sort of marginal gain
right so then it might be that they
become redundant and there's maybe sort
of information overload and that might
be a reason why you might be seeing
unfollowing or it might be that maybe
your initial choice in in following a
misinformation spreader was not
intentional right it wasn't related to
sort of their your desire to consume
misinformation and the more you have all
all them the more you kind of get
exposed to that you'll have sort of
regression to Domino kind going back to
your um your uh sort of um less exposed
uh uh
self the other way this could go is uh
sort of uh self-imposing uh
misinformation exposure being
self-imposing what we refer to as the
inertia hypothesis which is that the
higher exposure at time T1 is associated
with low un following at time T2 right
so this could be again due to many
reasons it could be that high exposure
at time T1 can be a consequence of
selective exposure like you are seeking
out what us you know researchers and
fact Checkers normatively decided as
misinformation so and and there
therefore you're sort of it's an
indication that you have demand for it
and there's uh sort of studies that
would indicate that it could also be
that the more you un you follow
misinformation spreaders the more
exposed you are uh to misinformation and
there's some uh evidence that the more
exposed you are the more you believe uh
in misinformation so it could be um
basically the cause of uh believing uh
in in misinformation which would make it
less likely that you would
unfollow so we didn't necessarily know I
I just want to I want to kind of poll
people and have you all sort of
pre-register your your predictions so
who thinks it's going to be the
reversion
hypothesis okay who thinks is going to
be the inertia hypo
is okay we're all very pessimistic here
great all right so uh that's the one set
of questions that we had in mind uh the
other set were related to ideology
that's obviously very commonly studied
Factor uh in past work on misinformation
we hypothesize that liberals will be
more likely to unfollow misinformation
spreaders this is our hypothesis three
uh there is some evidence irrespective
of it being misinformation that
apparently liberals just break ties more
quickly so um uh
that's uh that's one reason as to why we
were expecting that the other reason is
that most misinformation that's out
there tends to have a conservative
leaning so that might be also misalign
with your uh with your thinking and
there might be another reason why you
might be more likely to
unfollow we also expected the
politically extreme users to be less
likely to unfollow and there's some
evidence for that as a function of
passwor showing demand for
misinformation right so that is evidence
for increased misinformation exposure
for ideologically extreme people uh uh
in in P work um so um that's our
hypothesis for and um and the um um the
the the fifth hypothesis was that there
would be an interaction with a negative
interaction with conservativism and
ideological strength in that
conservative extreme people would be
much less likely to unfollow compared to
conservative uh uh sorry uh extreme
extreme liberals so uh the interaction
uh here so those were the kind of high
level questions that we had uh we had in
mind um just tell you a little bit about
our data I'm really masking a lot of the
nigr here but imagine so we have this
network first we are focused on health
misinformation in this work and this was
partly due to sort of funding reasons
but also partly due to uh we thought
that it might be easier to intervene in
on Mis Health misinformation as opposed
to let's say political IC misinformation
uh again this is we're building towards
our our experimental work so we
identified Health misinformation rumors
from p toact in March
2023 uh and identified the people who
shared them uh both to the URLs tweets
and R tweets and so forth we uh filtered
out uh debunking uh tweets uh and at the
end uh also uh limited our attention to
uh spreaders that have less than 20,000
followers so our goal again was one to
study regular users but to again due to
API limits as well that's like those are
the two sort of practical and thetical
reasons uh so that gives us uh 5.6 uh,
spreaders we collected their followers
uh gives us these edges those are the
edges that we really want to understand
are they are they disappearing and what
which ones of those are are disappearing
so to study this predictor uh world we
are living in only focused on these bold
edges uh we limited our attention to
obviously the accounts that were
existing in the two time stamps to make
sure that it's not the node that
disappears but the edge that disappears
uh and we also limited our attention to
the cases where we can identify the
relevant co-variate information like uh
the Tweet follower following count and
ideology ideology is the most limiting
one uh I'll have I'm happy to talk about
um robustness checks that we've done to
see if what happens if we include the
people for whom we don't have ideology
but I'll skip that here um so this gives
us uh the the misinformation spreader
edges as I said we wanted to understand
how that compares to a control group and
to make that be comparable we basically
fix our analysis on the followers so for
the followers we identify alars uh other
people that they follow uh that don't
spread misinformation so these are the
the dotted edges and when we're looking
at this prevalence question we're going
to be comparing comparing uh the the
bolded versus dotted edges uh we
couldn't do it for everyone due to uh
API limitations there are too many
followers for whom to get uh friend
information and that's is you know back
in the day when Twitter uh had an API uh
that that worked for for most even in
that case uh the network stuff was quite
limited so uh that's why we sample
25,000 active uh followers uh from that
uh modeling sample um and and focus on
on on on those on that group yeah and
want detail the misinformation rumor
URLs when were they classified as
misinformation like were they known to
be misinformation at the time of sharing
were they classified later that is a
great uh so yeah we do not have that
uh we do not have that um information
that is true it might be that they don't
know at the time uh we did not limit it
to the case maybe could have been like
they are identified in March and then in
April we do that collection so I think
we did it both at the both in March so
there might be some cases where they're
not debunked uh uh right away yeah great
question um okay so just to give you
some sort of more intuition about our
sample I'll just give you some
descriptive analysis so here we're
looking at the ideology of the followers
uh in our in our uh sample and how you
know the count of those you can that
most followers are conservative uh you
can most of the mass is happening here
but it's a bodal v-shaped uh uh uh you
know distribution consistent with pass
work uh but you can see that also they
tend to be a lot more extreme compared
to uh our liberal sample uh we also want
to understand the sort of questions
around entrenchment like how many follow
how many misinformation spreaders a
given person is is following so here
we're looking at that
distribution you can see that it's high
uh it's right skewed uh most people
that's that's a positive finding right
most people follow only one
misinformation spreader so if you could
intervene and break that tie we could
sort of Disconnect them from this
misinformation at least the health
misinformation world uh but there are
these people that are highly entrenched
uh and it's it's a larger uh subgroup
for conservatives so conservatives are
uh following more misinformation
spreaders uh than than liberals yeah
techology estimated by the like counts
of each person oh right sorry yeah this
is using the the the the uh B model by
barbar at all uh uh that basically is uh
based on uh starts with who you directly
follow but it's it's basically uh not
only as a function of that but as a
function of who you follow who also
follows and and so forth but it's it's
based on the network
yeah um and and it's sort of well
evaluated in past work uh as well so
that's one of the reasons why we we we
adapted that
work um so for the for these high L
trench people we want to understand uh
who they are uh so focusing on the top
10% of followers is a function of the
number of spreaders that they follow uh
we can see that uh they are more extreme
this is the absolute ideology right so
you know both High uh positive and high
negative values uh so that's that that
one has a High zcore
conservative they tend to be
conservative as seen by this is liberal
being negative but there is also things
that are sort of more unique to our case
for instance we again these would we
would expect from past work but related
to our work we also see that um they
tend to be more active uh but they also
their ties to misinformation spreaders
are uh more reciprocated right so it's
uh and this uh if you look at the
broader reciprocation uh rate it
actually to to us it was um astonishing
it was 69% of edges to misinformation
spreaders are are reciprocated which is
quite High uh and we see that it's
actually driven by a few spreaders so a
lot a few spreaders are seems like maybe
they are uh engaging in maybe followback
strategies to try to keep keep people in
and unfortunately as we will see later
on The Talk this probably is a good
strategy or it could be that they are in
these sort of tight lit uh communities
uh as well okay so the results um how
often our Mis information spread is
unfollowed and how does that compare to
unfollowing rate of nons spreaders this
is where we start seeing you know not I
guess unfortunate uh results uh so here
we're looking at uh the uh unfollowing
rates uh and obviously we have a smaller
number of spreaders in our sample so
that's why we have higher variance for
that group but uh we can see that uh un
following rate is quite uh low un
following is really rare so only three
roughly 3% of the edges disappeared in
the uh from March to
October uh and
unfortunately uh they are stickier those
edges are stickier than uh connections
to uh non-s spreaders right so uh users
uh are 31% more likely to unfollow non-
misinformation spreaders than spreaders
which is it un
like you know I guess unfortunate
finding here yeah a Qui question about
the non the Alters right yeah um were
you following like a matching strategy
there like how we did not do that yeah
that is um we this is uh like we don't
have as a function of um we had a model
where we were uh controlling for uh uh
you know um the um their number of
followers and like various
characteristics that we can identify
activity level you're not going to get
unfollowed if you don't say anything
yeah yeah no absolutely so again we have
uh the mo so in the model we don't mat
so we're not doing matching in the uh
the sort of regression model we do
control for uh the the activity level
unfortunately that's not the model so
I'm I'm going to only show you the the
sort of be bones comparison uh between
the two groups uh so um but yeah we
haven't done matching so I think that's
a that's definitely a thing to to to try
out model where you do uh where you do
control does it it still is that they
are they are still uh higher uh High
rates
yay yeah um but compar so we also want
to have another context so comparison to
past studies uh to to make them
comparable past studies are looking at
like monthly unfollowing rates so we had
to uh make put them in the same scale uh
the earlier studies in 2010s turns out
people are un following at higher rates
uh even the later studies where you have
like uh 2018 and 17 our unfollowing
rates are still lower compared comped uh
to to those so uh so what we're finding
is uh lower unfollowing rates compared
to past work and I didn't includeed here
but there's a very interesting study by
Kaiser at all where they looked at
people's unfollowing intentions so this
was an experimental work where they
asked people if whether they would
unfollow someone who's spreading
misinformation and they were asking
questions around ideology um so uh it's
it's not Apples to Apples comparison
because it's a like liquored scale uh
but you sort of intuitively what I would
expect based on that which was sort of
people's range was at like two out of
five uh this is quite low right so again
people are not we these edges are are
sticky uh very quickly again I'm not
showing you the the the the full model
but just uh basically we we had this um
null model assuming what what what if if
the whether the person is is a spreader
or not doesn't matter while this sort of
random unfollowing can be sort of
thought about as random sampling users
to unfollow with without replacement um
and which is basically can be
represented by this hyper geometric uh
distribution so the the purple is what
you would expect under this null model
and the red is what you expect in terms
of the number of uh um actual
misinformation edges that are being uh
broken so again they're different these
these people are are uh being uh
unfollowed much less often um so now two
predictors of of
unfollowing um so here we used this
robust logistic regression uh model uh
we also had the bin multi-level
regression model where we had random
effects for for the spreader uh they
give similar results the second model is
a lot the Bing model is a lot more
costly so I'm just showing you the
robust regression logistic regression
models which happens when you have large
amounts of data you don't really
generally need those fancier models uh
so um the first thing that we're seeing
is that reciprocity is the biggest
predictor right the re icated ties are
just broken in much much uh less uh uh
um frequent ways uh it's more important
than ideology which is you know like we
have a really high intuition about like
what what ideology would do here so the
second important is the ideology which
supports our hypothesis three that is
liberals are more likely to to
unfollow um now to the reversion versus
uh um inertia hypothesis at the end of
the day measures are pretty crude
because those are the ones that we had
access to from uh from uh the API uh but
according to the measures that we have
access to which is basically number of
spreaders that you follow and how much
those spreaders are talking which all
would kind of uh relate to how much
you're exposed to uh uh misinformation
that both of those are pointing to
reversion hypothesis so the more you
follow that time T1 the more you're
likely to unfollow at time two for T2
for each of these uh uh each of these
edges which is the one positive thing
that we have here um the the SEC the
hypothesis 4 we were we were expecting
that ideologically extreme people to
unfollow uh less often we did not see
that uh we see a barely significant and
positive effect for extremity so which
is really sort of baffling um but I'll
tell you a little bit more about that as
we talk about the interactions so we
didn't here hypothesis four refuted
three supported and we see the support
for reversion hypothesis yeah one more
detail the the marginal effect it says
probability scale so these are not odds
ratios yeah these are converted to
increase in probability okay yeah and so
the but the raw probabilities you would
said it was like 0304 so that's actually
a pretty big
effect the absolutely yeah it is a huge
effect yeah it's like proportionally it
is yeah it's going from uh 3 to yeah
Point 3 to point you know I guess it's
negative so it's going to be 0.1
something something yes absolutely yeah
it affected by how many people the
spreader is following or back or is it
just any reciprocity so we did yeah we
only looked at the reciprocity over the
edge that's a great uh that's a great
question we didn't look at uh just
generally like as a strategy what are
they doing we had we had sort of ideas
around like more complex Network things
of like you know you know Triads are
closed and and so for so we didn't we
didn't do any of these things yet but
that's I think that would be a pretty
easy one to to add on yeah good question
yeah is there a difference between an
account like being unfollowed and that
account possibly being like banned if it
was spreading Miss so banned yeah so we
remove those exactly because otherwise
you would mistake and say oh you
unfollow the person so we are limiting
our attention so we had all the these
checks uh of both both time periods to
make sure that the accounts still
existed uh and and uh so we also had a
we looked at whether people leaving the
platform varies across misinformation
spreaders versus others that's not in
this work but uh uh that's another
interesting inquiry
question okay so interactions the first
one was we found this overall reversion
hypothesis like evidence for that as
opposed to inertia the question is is
that really true for across uh to two
IDE I was going to say parties but we
really have ideology as our measure uh
so here we again have the marginal
effect but now separated uh by the
conservatives and liberals so what we're
finding here is that uh reversion
hypothesis holds separately for both
liberals and conservatives both of the
like everything is above zero right uh
but the effect is 1.7 times as strong
for liberals so liberals who are
following more misinformation spreaders
are a lot more likely to unfollow at
time T T2 uh but it it still holds even
though the effect is small for
conservatives as well so the even the
conservatives are following a lot are
are unfollowing uh more more often now
the ideological strength and and
ideology which is a weird interaction
but again let's remember the main effect
was the hypothesis 4 was technically
refuted we were seeing a near Z and
positive average mean effect of
ideological extremity on unfollowing
right so people who are extreme were uh
un unfollowing uh more often but as it
turns out this was masking uh a large
partisan asymmetry between the two
groups so here we're looking at the
margin marginal effect of uh extremity
for conservatives and liberals
separately and now we're seeing that
extreme conservatives are less likely to
unfollow versus extreme Liberals are a
lot more likely to unfollow so the the
the on average it ended up being sort of
um non-significant positive but in in in
pract if you look at them separately
extreme Liberals are are unfollowing
while extreme conservatives are are not
so this is support for hypothesis 5
where uh looking at the interaction okay
so limitations um
many uh so one our way of identifying
this information was high Precision but
presumably low recall right we are only
looking at things that ptoa says are
misinformation uh we uh focused on
regular spreaders and patterns might
vary significantly for uh for you
know Elites like people who are who are
extremely popular um and um what we call
unfollowing also includes the the
spreader blocking the person right we
think that's less likely but um uh still
I think to to acknowledge our study
period is well weird because musk so uh
so there was a lot happening in in how
people sort of thought about uh uh
Twitter or X at the time so uh un clear
if this would generalize to other
periods and the other unfortunate
reality is that um we might today say oh
my God it would be so cool to get this
other data we won't be able to so
unfortunately edits to the study in
terms of data collection are pretty
Limited at this point because of uh the
API limits uh but just a few concluding
uh thoughts here un following rate is
really rare rare compared to control
group past studies and unfollowing
intentions this
discrepancy between what people what
people say their intentions are versus
what we are seeing in in here here uh I
think has important implications one is
that like hypothetical studies do not
generally capture what people actually
do this is not a criticism of this great
work I think it's a great work just to
know that they capture different things
right in the same way as like surveys
and and and and the social media perhaps
capture capture different things but
also that this is encouraging for those
of us that want to intervene like people
say they want to unfollow so the
question is maybe they're missing the
information uh to act on uh to to
unfollow these uh spreaders so this is
room for uh making people move towards
their intended or uh at least stated
goals so reciprocity was a really strong
predictor this again I think has
implications at least that's informing
our study uh where we kind of want to
have our best shots so if you want to
have your best shot maybe first approach
trying to break ties that are not
reciprocated so that's uh that that's
one idea um
we found stronger evidence for reversion
hypothesis as opposed to inertia but we
don't know the mechanism and again the
mechanism matters for how you intervene
right if it is um sort of
information redundancy then you might
want to in your message remind the
person that this person is just like
creating information overload for you
versus if it is like the regression to
the mean you just want to remind people
hey by the way you're following a
misinformation spreader so we don't know
which one yet so we can't really uh
figure fig that out but maybe
experimental studies will give us that
and unfortunate thing this is not
surprising um extreme conservatives are
more likely to consume his information
that we already knew from past work what
our work adds here is that we are also
seeing that they are less likely to
severe ties to spread misinformation and
they are even less likely uh to severe
those ties the more spreaders that they
follow so unfortunately this is the
group that is biggest concern and this
is a big challenge for those of us that
want to intervene this
space need the more sort of most
intervention but perhaps the most
resistant uh to the intervention
here
finally most importantly um thanks to
collaborators Josh who is a fantastic uh
doctoral student he led this work from
uh uh from you know basically start to
finish he's doing all of the sorry I'm
getting updates no not updates skip skip
updates um so okay so he did all the
great stuff all the good stuff
attributable to him all the bad stuff
attributable to me and his co-advisor
Eric gilber uh and and uh and also
thanks to Mercury project who's who's
supporting this this work okay so let's
see how how much do I
have t Twi okay excellent so I'll I'll
go into the second okay yeah ask you one
question yeah so this last Point are you
able to for the ideology of the spreader
because most people who are spreading
this information are
conservative you would you could imagine
that Liberals are more likely to
unfollow those folks naturally so I'm
curious is this really that
conservatives are more likely to consume
this or is more likely that people at
either extreme are more likely but it
just happens to be that most of the
accounts frous information are
conservative I mean so it is true that
definitely the most that are out there
are conservative and we did not we
should we can uh like in the in the edge
characteristics we can have like
misalignment in in ideology as a as a
predictor we did not do that yet I think
that might be a good one to add I should
say just sort of empirically looking at
our our uh uh the examples that we we've
seen so we looked at some of these um
spreaders and and and the misinformation
that's being spread there
is it's conservatives but there are
there are those that are coming from the
the liberal side and in fact uh the the
I didn't go into the details of our uh
sampling strategy if you if you just get
everything then we were really
oversampling from uh part some spreaders
and it was end ending up that
one liberal spreader was spread one
thing that got really a lot of uh
attention uh so we basically were we had
this like balancing uh uh
um um sampling strategy that try to keep
them as balanced as possible uh but we
did not and we should we should probably
add that in our models yeah I wonder if
there's a way to look at possibly like I
guess almost people s talk about like
algorithmic pipelines if you interact
with like one page then you're more
likely to be exposed to like another
page and then does that then affect the
the amount that people are following
based off of how much just the um what
just the algorithm of the website or the
social media website sort of saying that
oh if it knows that people who follow
these types of things are more likely to
keep on interacting with their website
if they continue to feed the this
information this types of information or
like this sort of like level is that
sort of like some so we're not we're not
accounting for sort of algorith effect
so like what you're being exposed to
from the spreader in terms of like which
things that they share you're seeing um
and so and I think there's an
interesting question around like what
are um demand effects what are
algorithmic effects and really these
feedback loops are really really really
really hard to account for uh you know
both like methodologically but also for
us since we do not have access uh to to
that information so it's not we we're
not we really are we don't know exactly
what is like why we're just looking it
in the current state how are people
unfollowing uh so for for us especially
for our experimental work we can be a
little bit agnostic to that because like
we want to change the world as it exists
today and it might be partly due to
demand which I I think I I would assume
it's more demand than algorithmic but it
could be absolutely could be a
combination uh for sure and uh future
work that can get access to that kind of
uh data uh would be really valuable I
unfortunately we're going the other
direction of even the simpler data that
we got access to we no longer can get
access to anymore so but you know yeah
good good good question okay so now um
I'll talk about the second study more
briefly so this is um now we're thinking
about environment in a sort of a
different way which is that which is we
we were thinking around this problem of
polarization this time sort of out party
hate and how can we sort of change that
world and there are really interesting
findings from from past work in
political communication as to how we do
that our goal in this work is to deliver
those things in a fun and engaging space
so people will want to do them right so
that's that's the main goal and this is
where we have our our game guessing I'm
not going to spend much time in trying
to motivate partisan hostility is high
it's bad and there are perhaps ways to
fix it right so um and there are really
interesting studies here one of them is
this Mega study that's um sort of being
at least build up at Stanford uh with
you know contributions from various
Scholars um from around the world but
this Mega studies studied various
different interventions and found that
one of the most promising ones was
correcting uh misperceptions right so
what do I mean by that there are all
kinds of misperceptions you might have
uh about uh the other party um the one
that is uh of attention of sort of our
focus is uh is that people perceive out
party supporters to be more extreme than
they are right uh so uh let's take for
an example let's look at this question
what percentage of Republicans support
requiring background checks for gun
purchases at Private Sales or gun shows
so who here thinks that's at least
20% okay at least so we're going to hope
we're going to have some hands go down
over time at least uh at least
50% at least uh
60% okay well so you you guys are you
have you're you're better than most but
the idea the answer is actually 82%
right so you might not imagine
uh that uh that Republicans would have
such a a position so our goal the idea
is in the past work that you uh correct
such misperceptions this is done in lab
settings uh and again our goal is change
the environment take people from the lab
put them in a game setting try to
deliver same type of intervention and
see what happens with that so why
through games well they're easier to
play than talking politic politics right
uh that appeals to a wider audience um
it you can also design them in a way to
create a wide range of interactions
between between players and really games
create this sort of magic circle around
the players where you have a different
like psychological and so sort of social
um mindset that you get into so that you
can sort of break people away from their
political
identities uh there was a lot of
thinking that went into uh what we
wanted to get out of our uh game uh so
the our design principles for this game
that I'm going to show you was that we
wanted no prior political knowledge
requirement because we wanted to be as
broadly accessible as possible we want
to minimize partisan cues to take people
out of their sort of uh party ID uh uh
uh uh thinking Cooperative games uh so
that people can uh sort of have this
positive interaction uh with someone uh
uh and slow thinking uh we want to get
people to really reflect on the
information that that was being provided
as opposed to sort of fast actions uh
and we also included in-game messages um
uh to to ex to Eng allow people to
engage with with each other in in deep
ways so what's the game the game is
called uh guessing uh guessing in a
synchronized way uh this is not the most
popular uh board game but wavelength has
anyone here played wavelength before I
see some nuts okay great so this is
basically wavelength with some political
stuff injected into it and done in an
online world as opposed to in in a board
game setting so pairs of players are
randomly matched together and play five
rounds of games in each round two
players are shown a question they work
together as as a team to provide clues
and guess the answer so that's kind of
the high level thing um let me show you
like what the game looks like so imagine
so here you you are matched with u ali
uh you can see that our our uh sort of
icons are really sort of avoid devoid of
like blues and reds and any kind of
political ID information you can have
conversations to sort of have a friendly
uh introduction uh initial phase guess
guess phase you're given a question what
percent of adults have seen the movie
Titanic uh and you're going to make a
guest you each are separately making a
guest so you slide this uh slider to
make your guess uh and uh in the next
round one of you is going to be a clue
Giver the other one is going to be the
guesser uh so the clue Giver sees this
information it sees that the right right
answer is 70% right now you need to give
the other person just one word to get
them to guess 70% and you're given this
target number and you're given a scale
hot to cold so you to give something
that says 70% cold I must say I'm like
I'm not a game person I I was terrible
like all in all of our our trials I was
the worst in in the in the team uh with
this with this kind of effort but people
can be really creative what kind of Cl
do they say like Blockbuster like imply
that lots of people saw it or what oh so
no you need to give you need to give
something that is in the scale of hot to
cold so because the questions like
change a lot it's not about the question
the the clue should be as a function of
the scale so it might be that maybe
you're going to say lemonade right like
lemon it's not it's not sun it's not an
Antarctica it's like something that is
like cold but not not super cold which
is why again I like I think I I was I
was overthinking this game more than
many others uh but so you might you you
might say lemonade and based on lemonade
now this other person is supposed to
pick a pick a number the reason that we
want the clue to be not about the
question is that again it should be less
about the the political knowledge when
the question is about politics but
really is like devoid of that so you can
think about something else uh so if you
guys if you if your uh guesser guesses
something close enough you got you get
points and then you have you do this
like SE five rounds at the end of which
you kind of get get this uh result uh of
how well you it overall like your
guesses and the actual number and the
score that you
got so this is a game we basically use
this game in an experimental procedure
to test how we can deliver uh
misinformation uh sorry Mis
misperception correcting interventions
in this case so the way that we did this
is we pre-registered a between subjects
MK experiment so we're only asking
people questions around their
polarization or you know mediators and
and moderators who were interested in at
the very end so we're only looking at
differences between groups what are our
groups we had three versions the control
group where there is no political
question at all mixed version where some
of the questions are political some are
not and fully political where all of the
questions are political right so um we
wanted to understand you know we didn't
know if the mix versus fully would be
better because you know fully provides
more corrections but there might also
more reactants so that was our our
reason as to why we had these three
groups we had a postgame survey asking
about the outcome of Interest mediators
and moderators I'm not going to talk
about the mediators and moderators here
I'm just going to focus on the the main
finding uh because we had our uh um um
Power analysis before we knew how many
participants we needed uh so 665 is is
what we got um our political questions
are coming from National representative
uh surveys like NES and and uh CES and
GSS uh
and there are many questions that we
could have chosen we basically again
went back to MK to try to assess uh the
size of misperception so we want to
understand how how people get the answer
wrong especially for the odd party and
we picked the questions that had the
largest misperception right uh so that
was done before now we found the
questions for which people we think are
Mis understanding the other side and
those are the questions that we use the
main hypothesis was that players playing
the mixed and fully political versions
of the game will have lower out party
hostility and will show higher
willingness to talk to out party
supporters compared to control version
we did not have again a hypothesis
comparing the mixed and fully because
again we thought there are reasons that
it could go uh it could go both ways um
the results uh what were results
unfortunately uh there was no main
significant main effect on reducing out
party
hostility uh but it it did reduce out
party hostility among Democrats towards
Republicans uh and I'll be happy to talk
to you about our analysis that suggests
why we have the results that we have if
we have the time at the end um and we
also saw for both groups increased
willingness to talk to talk about
politics uh with the out party members
right so for one of them it works for
the other not so much was there um equal
out party hostility beforeand between
the two right uh so the great question
so it was actually I believe so this is
this kind of also goes back to why we
see these differences there are two
reasons why we see these differences uh
I'll quickly say our Republicans are
weird uh so in that there if you look at
the the hostility that you that you see
in our group versus other studies that
are looking at effective polarization
it's lower and also they are uh their uh
misunderstandings of the other side are
also goes the other way that it's like
they sometimes think that Democrats are
less uh uh less uh liberal than Li
extreme extreme than they are uh and
they moved in different way so and this
is the thing that we actually have seen
many online politics exactly so that's
absolutely so that's one of the reasons
why I think we are seeing the difference
the other thing is again our initial M
Turk experiment we chose the the
questions that the largest misperception
but it turns out again we chose for
Democrats questions where Republicans
thought they were less extreme than they
were so we were in the in our
intervention we were telling people no
no actually Democrats are you know more
extreme than you think they are so
that's I think Parton we that you know
in in retrospect we did not imagine that
this would be the case so we uh that's
you know uh future work I guess um but
anyway so the the thing that was you
know I'm an High School information
person so it's the thing that we I think
we can uh contribute here is political
communication Scholars are doing all
these great work to identify like
theoretical reasons as to why we deliver
the things that we do our thing was like
we need to make this fun so uh so the
the answer I guess here is that people
did indeed find uh find that uh to be
fun so we think that once we sort of
figure out these uh issues it could be
an encouraging way to to deliver the uh
the
interventions okay so then here again
the idea was the change in environment
and uh to make things fun uh uh so that
they can scale the a asymmetry is
concerning again I'm happy to talk more
about the reasons that's why we have uh
seen that the
the game is there you know if you want
to play with your friends just make sure
that you have at least two people
otherwise you're going to be waiting for
for a while to be matched uh thanks to
ashon who was a fantastic doctoral
student and that was a fantastic
assistant professor at UT Austin he led
this project start to finish just really
should get all the credit along with our
undergraduate students who were who are
so helpful in in helping us uh sort of
design this game and tested and so forth
and again uh the this time the
co-advisor being uh Paul Resnik so yeah
that's all I have um thank
you all right we got a few minutes for
discussion and
questions
I'm just curious how did how did this
idea the GU s game idea like appear like
why pick a game like what was the
motivation I think this is a super cool
project just curious yeah um I don't
know how it came about but so the
motivation is is like sort of what I
said which is that um there is like
reactance when you're trying to to
deliver all of these interventions try
to change people's uh attitudes and and
and behaviors so we were trying to think
about like what environments would make
it such that those kinds of things are
less likely to happen so that's one
thing that is like they will uh there
won't be as much of a of a reaction a
negative reaction but also again things
that just people will want to do so as
you're like because you like you know
listening all of this like political
communication work of like you know
media literacy like get people to talk
to each other and like how do we how do
how do we do that right so how do we
make it such that I'm not going to pay
you money to for you to come to the lab
for you to do that so that it's a thing
that people want to do repeatedly and
and and and learn from so so that was
the main goal of the the game itself um
like or G using games period I do think
that maybe we started with a harder than
necessary uh game like we made it again
we had like oh people should collaborate
you know cooperate and all of these
things there were like simpler versions
where you can have um people just play
games on their own for them to correct
misperceptions and like gamify this uh
this uh problem uh and now sort of in
the process of trying to figure out that
especially ashon who's you know again is
leading this effort and I'm hoping that
he's going to have the sort of breath of
of games that we're going to have but
the IDE is really sort of like gamify
things and and people will want to do
them so there's also a picture of like a
chat thing on the side did you look into
like what how people were communicating
on that chat we did uh I mean it was
more like qualitative as opposed so by
the way the chat is disabled during the
guessing part because you don't want
people to be giving each other extra
information it's only sort of in the
beginning like hi and it's more you're
sort of seeing more like positive things
of like oh man this is great you know
cool I thought this was fun or so it's
and and I think that we did not um try
to design over design that but we have a
lot of work in uh sort of HCR work that
would say like once you have a put a
chat thing there it could go in all
kinds of ways right could people could
be like nasty to each other but because
it's a Cooperative game we were
expecting there not to be as many sort
of issues there but just like allowing
people to make this be more sort of fun
and interactive so that was our our our
goal uh yeah I think just just
qualitative analysis is what we have
there but uh as you have like
a a whole portfolio of games in some
games chat can go in wrong ways like if
you're like trying to get you know
Democrats and Republicans to talk to
each other during a game here we didn't
have that uh then you might think about
like how do I design that that chat
function to make sure that it doesn't it
doesn't go s
ways
yeah yeah um was there any sort of
effect from like who was paired in the
game like I don't know if you ever look
to be like oh this was like a Democrat
Democrat matching or anything cuz I I
would assume that you'd be thinking that
that wouldn't have effect because it's
just about like kind of correcting the
assumptions in a masked way but like did
you look into that and was there so that
we definitely didn't power for that was
again it wasn't as uh important we were
not expecting to see an effect there I'm
trying to think if we have so there were
a thousand different analyses around
here uh I don't know if we looked into
this and uh
um I actually I don't remember I think I
expect there not to be an effect because
we try to remove as as as much as uh
possible and the clues are also not like
political Clues but this like the scale
that we're talking about
uh um so we were more about like whose
perceptions are being corrected but you
know we can we should certainly look
look into that and make sure that that
intuition is right yeah so this one
might be better asked over beer but I'm
curious you start with this vision of
Fairly substantial top down design to
shape Behavior like you know um the
lingen winner style like you know the
can't get under the bridge or like we
put these things mile away and plat you
know I would describe most platforms
have been Shin pretty far away from
anything nearly quite so um present it's
like you know in order to go follow this
person you need to go run a mile
something like that anything that would
put like substantial friction I'm
curious like given the framing like how
far would you go if you were actually
trying to do the sort of social design
here yeah yeah I I think that's a great
so great question that which is I think
it
maybe I think I have like different
answers for the first study versus the
second study in the second study we are
doing this you build the bridge and the
bridge is like designed to to shape
Behavior like we are going to have these
games with certain sort of values in
mind and people are still going to co-op
them and change them because that's what
people do with with with platforms but
there we have like really sort of top
down for the uh for the unfollowing uh
um you know um
study the question is like how do we
should is it the platforms that should
you know deliver that intervention or is
it you know us in a sort of smaller
smaller scale so I guess maybe in that
case I I would imagine that there would
be more reactant when it's at the
platform level and also we are really
like there is all kinds of values for
connections that are Beyond uh you know
uh the fact that whe whether somebody's
sharing misinformation so um I guess
there
uh what I would imagine what we we
should be doing is perhaps not as as top
down as as uh uh you know in this in
this other other case so yeah I don't
know I I feel like I I myself am not
satisfied with that answer I guess all
I'm saying is maybe like it it it uh it
depends but when it comes to us sort of
researchers deving these
games having those values embedded in
the in the games that were constructing
seems okay to me as long as you're not
like uh trying to deceive people uh uh
which you know we're um not at the end
so hopefully this will like if it's a
portfolio of of games that are out there
people will know it for what it is uh so
that which might limit it its impact uh
but you know okay yeah thank you yeah
and let's thank our speaker one more
time